The last Super Bowl was played right here.
Please don't tell me it was a classic.
Classic game.
80,000 people on their feet.
Seconds left on the clock,...
...so Hubie throws a Hail Mary.
Touchdown!
166 back online.
60 years ago, Earth was attacked.
We won the war, but they destroyed half the planet.
Everyone's been evacuated.
Nothing human remains.
We're here for drone repair.
We're the mop-up crew.
This is Jack Harper.
I'm good to go.
Two more weeks Jack, then we can finally leave and join the others.
Don't take any chances.
I've been watching you, Jack.
You're curious.
What are you looking for in those books?
Do they bring back old memories?
We have an unidentified impact.
Don't ask too many questions.
They are human.
This is ordering you to return to tower.
Jack.
How do you know my name?
They're firing on survivors.
Stand down!
What have you done?
You can't protect you.
They won't stop until they find me.
If you're looking for the truth, that's where you'll find it.
You need to know what happened.
What aren't you telling me?
Who are you?
Jack, this is ordering you to stand down.
I'm not gonna do that.
This is the only way.